So far, we have inspected the various variables of interest in the data.
We have looked at the allowed amount, charged amount and the payment amounts.
Now we will ask the question of correlations.
In asking if the variables are correlated,
we can ask if the correlation is non-linear or if the correlation is linear.
We can inspect this by looking at a scatter diagram of the variables.
Let us now inspect the scatter diagram of the two variables, f1 and f2.
Notice that we have plotted both the variables after scaling them.
Once you're done, you should have a graph that looks very much like this.
The scatter plot for these two variables are very linear.
What we can conclude from that is that the paid amounts are directly
proportional to the allowed amounts.
Similarly, we can look at the scatter plot of f0 and f1.
In this case, although we have some correlation,
it is not as linear as it is between f1 and f2.
We want to have a quantitative measurement of the correlation between
two variables.
We have already observed from the scatter plot of f1 and
f2 that they're linearly correlated.
We can calculate what is called the Pearson's correlation coefficient.
Let's first define this quantity.